[Music]
should we read this tony pizza post
yeah what is this man my boyfriend won't
stop calling me tony pizza
i
female21 wait there's 21 of them
nice
i female 21 and my boyfriend male 21
currently live together and have been
together about four months
to explain why we were living together
at the four-month mark we started out as
roommates but then started dating i have
to say my boyfriend has never been good
at pet names some early ones were little
stubster
and
sour meat
that's a good one
sour meat is a good one one of my
nicknames for him in comparison is
little bird ass
anyway about two weeks ago he starts
calling me tony pizza
this doesn't even make sense
and he uses it more often than my actual
name
he is obsessed
it honestly bothers me that he can't
even bother to find a somewhat nice
nickname for me i've had a couple of
conversations with him about it but he
says he can't think of anything better
what do i do
is this becoming a bigger problem or
should i even address it i hate being
tony pizza i mean the apps like that
[ __ ] like that the absolute
gall of her to say that her boyfriend
has never been good at pet names when
clearly he is the best yeah yeah
yeah he's the king yeah of pet names
yeah tower tower i mean sour meat is
incredible but tony pizza i mean that is
i tell this lady she will tear she will
leave him only to be disappointed
by the lack of creativity by every man
thereafter that's what i'm saying what
are you going to leave him for a dude
that's going to call you babe yeah
you're going to lay up your sweetheart
you're going to lay awake at night
just hearing his voice
it's going to haunt you oh yeah i love
nothing inside my little tony pizza okay
oh you think he uses it during sex yeah
yeah that's my little tony pizza you
like that tone
tone
yeah you like that [ __ ] tv
i know you [ __ ] with that [ __ ] right
there tp hey tom watch how i do this
watch how i lick this right here
that's just good huh tp
i don't know little miss pizza can we go
downtown tonight
hey tom won't you come over here and
give my dick that treatment huh do that
thing you do i love it
he's [ __ ] rolling his eyes in his
head oh
[ __ ] pizza this is how you do it [ __ ]
pizza
god damn tony pizza
goddamn pizza oh yeah oh [ __ ] pizza
you did it again i'm about to make you
some ranch
[Laughter]
oh i'm about to sprinkle my [ __ ]
parmesan on this [ __ ] pizza right
here
[Laughter]
what i have to say to that
how about
you get on your little pizza back
[Music]
and i take tone to the bone zone how
about that
imagine the absolute [ __ ] high of
calling your girlfriend tony pizza for
so long
and she hates it and she posts about it
online and now every single person
online thinks you're the funniest person
and is on your side yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah no i mean she's just straight up
wrong
that's a good nickname that is a dope
ass [ __ ] yeah i wish i was that funny
yeah
i wish i was funny enough to call her
tony pizza what's her actual name i
wonder who cares i mean it ain't better
than tony pizza i know introducing her
no no introducing her by her name but
then calling her tony pizza endearingly
in front of people
hey
hey tony pizza pass me that
oh tony pizza come on
tony pizza can you grab me some water
would you mind while you're up can you
just don't feel tony pizza it's just a
little yeah yeah it's a little thing i
do yeah tony pizza you call it
yeah it's like babe or whatever you know
tony pizza people are like that's
[ __ ] awesome
and then they tried that she's cool with
that no she's not yeah she [ __ ] hates
[Laughter]
yeah she [ __ ] she can't stand it
she can't stand me
but that's my little tony pizza right
there
it's my little tony pizza always just
you know getting a little fired up yeah
she's i mean she'll she'll get into it
eventually right
tony pizza yeah
that is
brutal what
for her to have to accept it well i'm
saying like it's endearing
it is
creative it's endearing like eventually
i don't know i feel like those things
shine more imagine on your wedding day
how cute it would be what five years
later this is at the altar and he's like
or no when he proposes
[ __ ] a pizza
no she opens the box there's a ring
right in the middle that that that's
fair yeah that's fair there's so much
yeah the wrist yeah the ring is a prince
albert yeah and it's his penis through
the ball okay all right
no what i was thinking was big sausage
pizza
i was thinking he gets on one knee and
he's like
tony pizza
that's how he started she's like you're
not gonna [ __ ] he's like just
tony pizza
my little tony pizza will you be my
pizza for now until death do us part i
think she's wrong
it's a great name it's a great nickname
sour meat i could understand sour meat
yeah i think that's funny that one's
just funny but it's it's not endearing
at all no i mean i'm on her side for
sour meat yeah and i'm on her side what
was the other one little substitute that
one's like kind of in the middle because
it's not really that funny i disagree i
think it's uh it's lazy
well stubster's kind of unique it's just
hard to say like dubster like you that
to me is lazy like you might stub your
toe one time he's like ah a little
stubster
okay
it's like it's it's lazy okay but
[ __ ]
tony pizza yeah
now little bird
has to be the worst name little bird
right
yeah
but is that then is that like
i have to say i'm biased because it took
me years to accept pet names what do you
mean even just babe
oh that [ __ ] you didn't like being babe
[Music]
what
why
i had a dark childhood bro
did your mom call you babe no
my mom said a lot of other things yeah i
know but i just babe i feel like
yeah i don't know it's not like
emasculating or anything no it's just
not that
she would use
um
she would
my
my wife would use
names that
people call me on the playground
[Laughter]
it didn't make me sad
now my mom would
occasionally use
like honey but it was always sort of
there's always in condescending contexts
okay
so yeah
you